foreign
[Music]
we're back we had a little technical
difficulty we accidentally let the kids
from Samford Community College in now we
got the real Stanford in their computers
work their internet's good they use
Google Chrome uh those other guys were
on uh you know using Android or
something like that but we're ready to
get started first a word from Bobby
fire hounsel as I call them uh your
nickname was fire because last time you
came in with absolute fire we almost
couldn't tame you as you were on the
podcast but go ahead give us the intro
out for this hey what's up I'm back and
the guy from the Michigan episode uh we
built our entrepreneurship Community
from Michigan to Stanford since we saw
you last it's called entrepreneur Power
Hour we're chaining out College founders
meet we're changing now Angel Investors
meet these College founders we're
changing the game entirely we got a
non-steer who's our community to lead
over at Stanford
um things are moving we launched The
Syndicate we're hype um but today uh
we're moving away from Michigan and
we're meeting the Stanford Killers uh
and so I'm hyped to Passover or not he's
going to get us rolling and introduce
this and Bobby love you Bobby I got a
question for you
is it true what they say about the post
my first million bump like uh yeah we'll
have kids like you know are you getting
kisses on the cheek around campus are
you uh do you get free lunch in the
cafeteria what was the library I mean my
girlfriend was starting to get jealous
she's like who who who's this the female
Founders are coming out of nowhere
yeah okay
[Laughter]
we need the we need the Conor McGregor
clip where he goes it's red panty night
when you sign to fight me you call home
you call your wife you say Conor
McGregor right made us we've done it
baby break out the red panties that's
what happens when uh when my first
building comes to your college campus
baby we've done it salmon Sean coming to
our campus
bring out the red Solo
got it
I'm the angel ambassadors of the female
Founders I don't know who to worry about
more
all right so let's get started go ahead
uh go ahead let's kick it off yeah well
cheers thanks so much seems like we're
put in this business podcast or Ninja's
podcast
um
nice yeah I mean we got a great group of
Stanford Founders over here and Bobby's
an absolute killer love that man dearly
and I hope that you're gonna love the
founders we have got a great Community
we're building it out so you're
interested in learning more you know
feel free to reach out to me I don't
want to spend too much time re-entering
so I'll introduce our first guy Tom
Tommy Peas I like to call him he's a
hardware dude he's actually the old head
of the group he's actually a master's
student doing a lot of cool stuff but I
don't want to steal Tommy's thunder so
I'll kind of let him take things from
here how old is old I'll let Tom answer
that because I actually have no idea how
old but 20 plus
well
um thanks and yeah thanks for the intro
uh Anon uh super pumped to be here
um should we dive right into the pitch
or yeah is it five minutes or two yeah I
think we have wait wait what's the
timing on these so I think we did too
many last time somewhere like three or
five three Bobby's saying let's do three
all right here here's the deal you you
got three minutes you got one where
we're not gonna interrupt you but after
that we could just jump in at any time
and interrupt you after that okay so
let's let's do it okay keep that in mind
cool so uh okay uh so hi Tom here uh
transcribe glass and we're building
wearable subtitles for the deaf part of
here essentially taking your Netflix or
YouTube captions and putting them heads
up
um hearing loss is a massive issue uh I
used to be pre-med so uh I guess a few
Med stats at you all day and that's what
I'm gonna do uh it affects close to half
a billion people it's twice as common as
in cancer or diabetes and it's growing
by 2050 one in 10 people will have a
disabling hearing loss it also is
comorbid with a lot of things including
dementia through three to five times
more likely to get dementia if you have
hearing loss despite everything I just
said Hearing Solutions today are
horrible they're really expensive two to
eight thousand dollars often out of
pocket for hearing aids because
Insurance like Medicare doesn't cover
them the biggest killer thing for me
though is that 75 of people who could
actually use hearing aids use absolutely
nothing if you talk to anyone who has a
hearing loss or try to hearing it what
they'll probably tell you is hey I
bought it put in my ear hated it put it
on the Shelf never use it again now
there's a really cool medical reason why
you know people hate hearing aids more
than glasses but we don't actually have
time for that so what we do know about
the deaf hard of hearing people like
myself is that we love cash and what's
not to love they're really you know cost
effective uh incredibly uh sorry keep
going I like it keep going incredibly
accurate uh and um you know intuitive
people know what captions are they know
how to use them uh in fact I've heard of
hearing people love captions so much
that we actually Sue Netflix uh and now
Netflix has to caption all of their
content so if you're watching your
foreign film with captions you know
thank your local deaf hard of hearing
person you know make sure to enunciate
so they you're you uh but yeah
um Pro tip
um we knew that captions were incredibly
valuable but we needed a way to get them
on your devices and into the real world
where you needed that for conversations
uh and we looked at all the AR players
we you know tried a whole bunch of AR
headsets uh to bring those captions into
your plw we made this really fancy chart
and we realized one thing
people don't actually use AR glasses
today no one uses them no one's wearing
them in this room I don't see them
around the campus except me
um there's a lot of reasons why AR
adoptions have been so shitty
um but um the fundamental trade-off in
rpna our thesis is this trade-off a
fully immersive content versus true
wearability at transcribed glass we're
focused on just critical information
like text and captions as a result we
built the lightest AR product with
all-day battery life and a form factor
you actually want to put on your head
now into me and describe this describe
the product what it looks like for the
listener because a lot of people aren't
watching oh yeah for sure so it's a
wearable device I actually have a demo
video I'd love to play it after it just
shows what it looks like through the
inside it's really quick but it's a
lightweight AR product it's designed in
a retrofit manner meaning it attaches to
your glasses a lot of your users are
older with here you already use glasses
so it can fit onto any glasses and work
Straight Out of the Box you have
numerous features like uh Focus
adjustment that are catered to the depth
part of hearing and it has an all-day
battery life and it's incredibly light
people tell us they don't notice when
they're wearing it you look through it
and you see subtitles uh text floating
in your field of view and you can
position it anywhere you want is that is
to clarify
I don't know if I'm too sci-fi here or
if this is your product but I'm talking
to you and it would be transcribing what
I'm saying
right there for your eyes right so it's
just live transcription of anything
you're hearing it basically just looks
for The Listener it looks basically like
Google Glass but it turns any set of
eyeglasses into a Google Glass looking
device so so sorry go ahead and you're
at the end of your time here so let's
wrap the pitch yeah yeah exactly so yeah
that's that's the product that's what
we're building
um users love it uh we have over 700
pre-orders uh completely inbound from
Awards we won we won you know for social
good Indian presidential gold medal you
won the health category of Stanford's
largest startup competition uh we also
have a tremendous inbound interest uh
from cinema halls and B2B they're all
required to provide these accommodations
uh and we recently signed an NDA was one
of the largest media companies as a way
to put captions into your field of view
uh now is also a great time to do this
hearing aids have been deregulated this
year which is crazy you you no longer
have to go to a doctor to get them or an
audiologist you can buy them over the
counter so our product can be right
there around next hearing aids at Best
Buy first time ever that this is
possible and finally last thing I want
to hit is you know we built a really
cool product but the immediate thing is
like hey why can't someone else build
this you know you have Fitbit and you
have 30 other versions of big bit
Hardware especially consumer Hardware is
inherently commoditizable the thing is
what we've done is our revenues do not
come from our Hardware sale they come
from the recurring subscription revenues
that we get
on this product
um and you know that scales really
heavily
um so I can talk more about that but
just want to wrap it up we're running a
pilot trout at Stanford this quarter
officially if you want I can connect you
to them and you can try out this product
uh that's also a picture of my co-care
in the corner of meeting the president
of India
um for this work
[Laughter]
picture of me with Drake
um all right so that's a great way to
end a pitch so you um two questions how
does it actually do the live
transcription is this software you guys
are writing are you using some open
source tools yeah AI what are you doing
yeah so we're right now using um
third-party as automated speech
recognition Services we're Source
agnostic meaning right now we support
three Google Microsoft IBM their
automated system that you know restream
the captions and display them here
um we are also uh able to do subtitle
files if you walk into a movie theater
you can load the subtitle file and
display it uh or another thing called uh
card interpreting
um where you can you know a person types
and then you can stream the captions to
your device we're moving towards a
non-device model that's Wi-Fi agnostic
uh and can work anywhere as these models
improve get better and decrease in
latency things like whisper
two questions question or Point number
one you're in luck I am a soon-to-be
hearing aid wearer and Sean has someone
in his life who wears one too I have a
hearing loss so I'm I'm actually in the
process of getting one now okay um the
biggest thing with my hearing aid or why
I have a hearing of my hearing loss is
not watching TV it's when I'm out in
public I can't hear the difference
between you talking to me and the
background noise of the restaurant it
all sounds like one thing to me so I
constantly have to lean in so I want to
know about that and number two
um
the whole dementia thing I learned about
that and I don't I remember uh reading a
little bit about it but but from my
understanding dementia the reason why
it's you why hearing people who have
hearing loss gets dementia is because
that part of their brain isn't working
and so they like part partially get a
little funky I think that's what it is
how does this actually solve that if I'm
still not using if I'm not hearing I'm
just reading yeah okay super good
question let me hit the first one first
um so yeah uh hearing loss the biggest
complaint was people who actually use
their hearing aids is high noise
settings I hate bars and I hate clubs as
a result of the well actually everyone
has a hard time hearing but I have a
much worse time hearing uh what we're
building here is adding directional
microphones so you can isolate the
speaker of interest uh so we're
targeting both through the model right
the ASR model voice reduction through
software and also Hardware uh orienting
directional microphones at the speaker
of interest that may be able to improve
uh the situation uh a bit but it is a it
is an inherent challenge
um right the other uh the other dresser
other point was dementia
um yes the the part of the brain isn't
being uh stimulated but the there
another thing is just the social
withdrawal that you get uh you just as a
deaf hard of hearing person if you have
hearing loss you hate going out it's
really hard and sounds sound weird
um so you you lose the quality of of
your social interactions and that was
draw the lack of stimulation that really
triggers dementia and a host of other
depression as well is actually very
comorbid as well as hearing loss
um and wouldn't this thing be more
embarrassing to wear than a thing in my
ear that no one could see exactly like
you like like I don't know man you take
those glasses off I might want to hook
up with you more than without them
that's uh that's an honor but uh
um
um yeah uh you know on our website we
say you can use this on dates so you can
use it on dates but uh our it won't work
but you can use it you could try it yeah
topic of it but
um so yeah welcome to the Pod my friend
our goal our goal is to integrate it
fully into the like glasses you know we
this is an early version of the form
factors was built on you know
exclusively Grant based funding uh that
we've gotten uh by other US state
department government of India
um but we're moving to an integrated
form factor in your glasses
um we also built it in a retrofo way
meaning mounting because most of our
deaf people part of hearing users
actually you already have glasses we
wanted to work with their existing
solution I agree
oh sorry I'm gonna give you my I'll give
you my reaction to this right so
I think you did a great job on your
pitch especially at the beginning uh the
problem section you did a fantastic job
you outlined it's a problem it's a
bigger problem than you think and it has
all these knock-on effects so you nailed
the problem part
on the solution part you're clearly a
smart guy and you are building something
that's cool and useful but I don't think
it's realistic for two reasons number
one like Sam said
I think that the thing looks a little
dorky and people are gonna have an
aversion to wearing it right now right
so you're like well this is V1 this is
the this is the equivalent of the big
giant cell phones that we used to have
before we got the cool like Sleek ones
and I believe you but you're in an arms
race against Google Facebook Apple all
these companies that basically everybody
wants to build AR glasses yeah it's like
the hottest thing outside of AI is AR
glasses okay whoever gets AR glasses
that's the new phone you can put the
screen on your eyes and so they're all
gonna put billions of dollars in making
the most lightweight
um glasses that have a computer in them
basically and so you're going to be
trying to slim down your form factor
using grant funding and all the stuff
and Apple and Google and Facebook are
going to be doing this with everything
that they've got and they're gonna get
there first most likely as to having the
the lightweight form factor and at that
point captions might just be a feature
or an app on top of their thing and and
so you're going to waste a ton of money
I think doing trying to get the hardware
to work when you're not going to be the
one who makes hardware for the masses to
wear on their their uh as like smart
glasses the big companies are gonna do
it so I think that's the problem now
the one thing you said that I'm just
gonna call out which is that you said uh
hearing aids hearing aids have been
deregulated this year so for the first
time ever you can sell them without you
know going through a doctor
that was the big light bulb moment for
me of oh there's a business opportunity
here it may not be the thing you want to
build because you're like sounds like
you're trying to do good in the world by
like changing the world and you know
helping people blah blah blah you know
that good stuff
but there's somebody out there like oh
cool DDC hearing aids gonna do that now
like you know that that's now more
possible than it was before because I
don't need the telemedicine component in
between
um and so I think that's actually the
real business opportunity out of all the
things you said and I think you're on
the right path but I don't think you're
going to be the one to do it I think the
big companies are going to make the
glasses and then the captions are going
to be a feature on top of those 100 uh
could I hit that point real quick
um yeah so I completely agree with you
Facebook is spending 10 to 15 billion a
year right now on their AR product you
know all of the Apple wants to come out
with ar glasses hopefully in 2024.
um we want them to validate the AR
Market
um we're no and the thing is was you
know let's say Facebook for example
they're building an AR headset they're
not going to validate it they're going
to own it they're going to own it
they're gonna validate it for you to go
own they're gonna own it 100 but they
need an immersive AR headset to run what
is the metaverse they want to build a
headset that can support their existing
platform Marx I mean Zach herberg's
vision is you know the meta burst this
immersive reality that cannot run on
transcribed glass and as a result that
cannot run on this lightweight porn
Factor all-day battery-like wearability
setup so we can much more quickly build
a wearable product because we're focused
on captions and critical information for
the deaf hard of hearing uh that that is
you know the the core focus of our
product it's building for wearability uh
and form factor right now for a core use
case of people who create need it not
that broader vision of Multiverse
Multiverse content yeah because there's
other companies so Snapchat wants to
Snapchat's doing it they just want to
put a camera on there to snap a photo
yeah right that's the only use case they
care about right now yeah Google wants
to put your notifications and your text
messages and your email on it right
um you know so everybody's got a
different vision and so it's not just
Facebook who's trying to do this you're
trying to build a whole Multiverse or
metaverse whatever the hell yeah it's
like you know everybody's trying to make
the thing that consumers will buy that
turns their glasses into a basically
yeah and um into some version of a phone
maybe a lightweight version first and so
I I don't buy that and uh yeah so for
that reason for that reason even though
I I think you're you're good intention
and you're a smart guy I don't think
this is an investable product what do
you think Sam
I agree but I do want to give you Kudos
because uh I think you creating
something Hardware related is ballsy and
I think it's awesome that you're you're
going this route as it is now no I I
don't think it's it's the way it is but
I have a feeling that if you keep going
down this route you're gonna find a
better solution soon and I actually
think you should continue to pursue it
but you're gonna find a you you've come
up with some interesting technology I
also like the fact that there's like an
inflection here which is that uh
hearing aids are now uh yeah deregulated
are deregulated and I think that those
are always good inflections when you can
pounce on those things but I don't know
if this is the right solution but it is
interesting technology that I think is
actually going to be used for something
else cool
um yeah and this is coming from
a half deaf guy so like I would not want
to use this as it is now but I I think
it's a cool problem you're trying to
solve and I think it's cool technology I
just don't think they're aligned cool
right on all right thanks Tom thanks so
much yeah thank you guys best of luck
our next one is going to start with the
big D democratizing all right whenever I
see whenever I see the big d uh uh I I'm
curious so what do we got yeah from
Gandalf the Gray we go to Frodo the
young snow home is the Freshman of the
group
um he's an absolute killer one of my
close friends
um he's got a pretty sick startup so
I'll I'll leave the rest to him so home
sell yours bro so come come democratize
us
what's up sharks my name is soham I'm
the founder of admin Yogi we're on a
mission to democratize college
admissions using the power of big data
and artificial intelligence
but before I can tell you a little bit
more about the business I first kind of
want to start with a personal story
about myself
I went to high school in one of the
largest public high schools Across
America down in good old Round Rock
Texas
my class had over a thousand students
including myself and although our
counselors were incredibly hard-working
and supportive they were also massively
under resourced so when it came time to
apply to college we were always at a
disadvantage compared to these
far wealthier privileged students who
could shell out literally thousands of
dollars for these private college
Consultants
and this is a nationwide problem
you see today if you want to get into
one of these Elite schools you'll need
Insider strategies but for the longest
time they've been maintained and gate
capped by this Mafia of six thousand
dollar
six thousand dollar College Consultants
now when I was applying to college one
of the strategies that I found the most
useful was getting to read through some
of my older Frank applications
reading terms are their essays
extracurriculars and awards was really
meaningful to me because I got to see
how they told their stories so in turn I
could learn how I wanted to tell my own
now with Ahmed Yogi I want to ensure
that everyone from rural Texas to the
bustling Big Apple can experience that
same feeling of magic
with all this platform this database of
over 5 000 real applications that were
accepted to Elite universities like
Harvard Stanford and MIT and these
applications are the real deal we're
talking essays Awards extracurriculars
SAT scores GPA you name it the whole
damn Edge a lot
sharks were a feasted
and we are a startup in 2023 so we'd be
remiss without mentioning AI so
we use an AI powered algorithm to match
high schoolers with students at their
dream schools who are successful
let's say there is an Indian student in
Texas he wants to study computer science
at Stanford University
he can read through my applications
which I spent hundreds of hours working
on for literally the price of a cup of
cotton
and what's really cool is as we start
the kind of stockpile this massive data
mode we can start to use artificial
intelligence to extract really high
level amazing insights that demyst it by
the admissions process turning it from
this confusing lock box into a precise
science
and then we can always become this
digital private consultant giving high
schoolers personalized instantaneous and
affordable recommendations
so I got a question yeah
um can you skip to the two parts about
the business so I want to know uh how
this makes money and I want to know are
you uh if you're raising money how much
are you raising and what's your
valuation absolutely you know those two
things so we started this business in
September of 2022 with zero dollars of
outside bunding we're on track to finish
our first year with 130 000 of Revenue
currently 85 in the bank
oh we're going to wow congratulations
thank you so you started this in
November uh so you the 2023 your full
fiscal year was 180 Grand oh
around yeah 180 by the end of 2023. oh
okay all right all right I got you yeah
so uh from September 2022 to August 2023
we'll have made 130 000 in gravity and
what's really exciting is we've actually
helped over 11 000 high schoolers with
their college applications and we think
that that impact is enormously
meaningful coming from a team of
students who all went to public high
schools so what do you charge how do you
make money on this yeah so college
students upload their applications on
our database and high schoolers pay to
unlock them so if I'm a high schooler
then I'm paying for every person's
application that I'm reading and we call
it Lowe's profiles which include
multiple applications essays Awards
activities United
gotcha and uh so you charge uh how much
to unlock one one application so it
ranges between five and ten dollars per
application and why are the college kids
uploading their thing that's a great
question so we pay college students to
upload their applications onto our
service we've actually built out this
direct integration with the common
application platform which is the
largest national platform for applying
to college and it takes literally 30
seconds for a college student to upload
everything from their extracurriculars
their essays to their activities lists
and we have over 5 000 applications on
our service and a lot of these are
coming from schools across the country
wow and how did you get the the
customers how did you get the people to
hear about this we think that
distribution is really important in 2023
so we have a tick tock of over 61 000
followers all organic and 30 million
organic social Impressions we think that
really marketing the Gen Z is super
important today because there's not a
single College consultancy out there
they can really say that they can access
61 000 minds of 17 18 year olds at any
given instant
so I'm shocked like we haven't made a
joke about like is the upsell if you're
playing to Harvard like to tell you not
to be an Asian person like has that
happened why haven't we made like this
joke yet why is this we're off our game
so are you raising money right now
at the moment we're not raising we uh
we've never had any durations we've
always been profitable since day one but
in the future we are open to exploring
I really want to invest more now yeah
yes great perfect answer yes that was
the perfect answer awesome job awesome
progress so far this is very very cool
but by the way I was gonna shout this
product out next podcast anyways I saw
you on Twitter and I saw I saw admit
Yogi on Twitter and I was like oh it's a
great idea they're getting college
students once you don't need your essay
anymore they're paying you a little bit
for it you already did all the hard work
so yeah whatever exactly in the database
and now they have this database of
college like admissions essays and like
the the stats and the resumes and all
that good stuff so I thought that was
really smart I was going to bring this
up anyhow
um that's it's funny that you're that
you're here I gotta give you props on
two things number one you do two things
really good in your pitch I want to call
out
the first is you said at the beginning
you go you know before I tell you you
know I'm the founder of Advent Yogi
here's what we do then you go before I
tell you about the business I gotta tell
you a personal story as to like you know
why I came up with this idea in the
first place and that's a great way to do
a pitch once you have somebody's
attention like if you're in the meeting
um and they can't really leave that's a
great way to to to start a pitch
um because it it shows your you know
founder fit with the problem but also
people just want to hear a story so uh
you you get them from going into kind of
this transactional like analysis mode to
storytelling mode and so I think that
was really really well done and uh and
then the fact that you actually have
traction is the the second good part of
your pitch like this is not a theory
this is something that you actually have
in motion now Sam give me your take of
uh would you invest in this why or why
not would I invest uh if I were to learn
like if you're taking this as a serious
company I mean you're only what are you
19 or 20 years old like you're a
freshman you've only been working on it
for a year or less than a year you've
got great traction I think uh the fact
that you're only charging five dollars
that's like uh I don't love that I think
it's really hard to build a big business
on five dollars
um so I would I would want to know about
what your average revenue per user is
but I think that you are a very
investable person so I definitely am
interested
um yeah do you have a question on that a
little bit yeah yeah so our average
customer spend right now is 130 so
people pay to unlock these profiles in
bulk anywhere from 1 to 50 profiles at
once and people on average want to
unlock 26 profiles of someone at the
dream school and all three of us are
really committed to this so we're
actually considering taking a leave of
absence to drop out work on this
full-time Etc how many students uh are a
plot like how big is the customer base
for this how many students are applying
to college
um or let's say you know yeah and like
kind of the serious callers where they'd
be willing to pay you know for something
like this how many students is that per
year yeah so in America there's 2.2
million students who are applying to
college every single year but if you
just narrow that to maybe the most elite
colleges then you have around 400 000 to
500 000 students every single year that
are coming into this month
and so how does this get huge given
given that what you just said right so
let's say it's 500 000 and let's say
even 20 of that market was to use
something like this so a hundred
thousand dollars or sorry 100 000
customers uh that would be like you know
the absolute like you guys are
dominating the market at that point
right like so what's that five million
absolutely that's a great question and
that's something we've actually thought
about a lot at admin Yogi so sorry just
to do the math if a hundred thousand
people did it you said about they spent
about 100 bucks each that'd be 10
million dollars in Revenue if if that
was the case right so correct yeah and
we're gonna we're gonna Define big as
like 50 million in Revenue we'll say
that's like the threshold of like things
get really interesting sure yeah so
currently the college admissions Market
is around 10 billion dollars but that's
just spending coming out of the top one
percent of Americans we think that by
providing more Affordable Services we
can reach the other 99 and not only
capture that massive initial Market but
also create a new one entirely and be
the biggest player in that space I think
that sounds good that that's sounds good
because it's democratizing but in
reality what's going to happen is you're
actually just gonna try to take that
same one percent because the one percent
care the most have the most money are
the most obsessed and maybe you expand
that to like you know the one to nine
percent uh of the most competitive you
know willing to pay type of customers uh
and it's actually never the the other 99
that uh that you get to be your customer
because the other 99 just don't have the
problem in the same way or don't have
the budget in the same way and so you
know it's very hard to capture that
customer versus the person that's taking
test prep that's hiring a college
consultant that's you know um you know
really really stressing about what
colleges they're going to go to they're
the ones who are willing to pay for a
new solution too that's that's really
interesting and that's actually the
Israel hypothesis that we had as well
that we're going to Target these one
percenters who are traditionally paying
for college consulting services in this
in the first place but actually with
this most recent round of early decision
or regular decision applications that
came out just two weeks ago received
floods like hundreds of emails in our
inbox from these students who were
traditionally underserved like we're
talking and Annie from rural Mississippi
first generation College applicant never
knew about traditional Consultants I
mean they were too expensive for her but
admin Yogi wasn't so right we initially
thought that hypothesis too but as we
started serving our customers really
collecting the data on this we realized
that that actually wasn't the case what
happened it's when Harvard's like you're
like oh man we're getting all these
robots uh you're or uh you know and then
the the universal college application I
forget what it's called like can they
ban you uh like can they pull API access
it can that can it work that way uh so
we integrate with the common application
which is agnostic to University so let's
say the Harvard University admissions
Department doesn't like us for whatever
reason we're not sourcing any kind of
data from them we're sourcing it from
this national uh National Standard right
I think what Sam's saying is if could
the Common App shut off your access yes
that's what I'm asking okay uh if the
common application wanted to they could
theoretically turn off API access but
again college students can still upload
their applications manually so it might
take five extra minutes to onboard a new
application on our service but
fundamentally high school or college
students own this data so they're in the
they have permission to upload it to
whatever platforms they want including
Avid yoga and William a date so here's
why here's why you kind of make me all
hot and bothered number one well
typically people are usually really good
at getting traffic to their website so
marketing or getting like hype and
things like that and a lot of times the
people who are great at that aren't
amazing at creating products and a lot
of times the people who are amazing at
creating products suck at marketing and
like getting eyeballs I'm I'm I've been
toying around your website right now it
looks cool it looks appealing it looks
well done and you're saying that you've
got all these customers early on I think
that that is like very very very
attractive like from a Founder's uh
perspective so I think you're really
fascinating the there is like I'm not
convinced that it could be a huge thing
but I am convinced that you could find
upsells that could potentially make it
big I think if I'm in your position
I wouldn't raise money and I think that
by the time you're 30 years old you can
be worth hundreds of millions of dollars
because you own a business that makes uh
30 or 40 million bucks that potentially
you could sell for a hundred million
dollars or something by the age of 28 or
something like that but like just the
fact that you've pulled off the the
because it's a Marketplace a bit because
you've already kind of cracked that code
I find that to be incredibly impressive
thank you so much yeah I uh I really
like this the one thing I would do is I
kind of feel like you're using the last
business model instead of the next
business model so I think what
like if somebody came to me today with
this trying to solve this problem of how
can I help people apply to colleges in a
way that helps them be more successful
I would say oh fantastic this should
feel like chat GPT so basically I should
basically be able to
go to go to some uh bot that's going to
basically say help me with my
application
with my essay write my essay or edit my
essay with my my application the you
know the information I put on my
application how to structure it better
or present it better
um and it should learn off of these
successful applications so it should
take a data set of successful and
unsuccessful applications and then it
should just do it for me versus a
marketplace where I need to go pick and
choose okay Jasmine got into Stanford
should I pay ten dollars to unlock her
essay okay then I unlock it now I need
to look at her essay and I need to
compare in my mind how to make her essay
how make my my essay more like her essay
no no no
I'll pay you 99 bucks just help me get
into college right like give me a you
know give me a 2X shot at getting into
my dream school because you have a chat
GPT that's trained on successful college
applications and it will write your
essay and structure your your
application and even do the application
and just let you click submit and go to
all these schools that's what I think
the like if I think about how how's
somebody going to do this in the next
three years that's what the solution
looks like Sean it's really funny that
you mentioned that because actually
that's the exact Vision that we had for
Advent Yogi we actually tweeted an MVP
of this chat gvt like chatbot they can
answer any question about college
admissions and it's like fine-tuned on
this proprietary data set we built this
massive data set of college applications
and we actually tweeted an MVP about it
a couple months ago but we really think
that with big data and artificial
intelligence especially with generative
AI we can provide students with these
hybrid personalized specific
recommendations for literally like you
said 100 bucks yeah because you know the
college application process first you
got to figure out what school should I
even apply to where do I want to go and
the chat back and forth about like well
where do you want to go it's like
well what do you care about do you care
about weather do you care about being
near home what do you care about oh cool
then we recommend these schools and okay
can you help me get in and then you're
comparing to like how much does the
college consultant cost
polish intelligence charges six thousand
dollars on average
cool so you say instead of six thousand
dollars pay 99 bucks once and get into
your dream school and like that's the
pitch that now that that I think is
really really compelling so if you were
doing that I would invest because I
think that is a very very big idea we
should we should go to the next one but
dude this is wildly impressive I saw uh
Sean but what you're saying it reminds
me I saw this tweet this lady was like
uh it just formed my heart today
that people were doing things in the old
school way I was on a train and I saw
two kids copying each other's homework
in their notebooks and it just brought
me back to better times before kids were
using chat gpd3 to to plagiarize one
another uh and so like I don't know if
that would I don't yeah I think that
that's like weird to hear how kids are
gonna be doing that in the future but
brother you're impressive
congratulations don't raise money by the
way just own the whole thing before you
go can you remind everyone just how how
old are you there are some speculates
I'm 19 years old wow
you're ahead of the game you are out of
the game you should take your leave of
absence but you should just stay right
next to the campus and just recruit
smart kids to come work for you for free
basically while you're uh while you're
building a company while they go to
class every day you should 100 bail by
the way you should 100 bail yeah yeah
yeah if you need help talking to your
mom uh I'll I'll call her and help you
out appreciate that Sean thank you cool
all right see ya
all right who's next so next up we got
Zayn and Matthew I like to call them the
two Twin Towers they're absolute menaces
the bone out candid
um you love them so let him take it away
there's a bunch of beauties American
Gladiator or Shark Tank a little bit of
a Blazer and Blazer
what a bunch of beauts let's get them up
here
he wasn't lying uh okay cool and we
gotta go a little bit faster because I
think we're taking a little too long on
each one of these so let's try to hit
the points just here's what you got to
do say what you're doing say why you're
doing it
tell us if you have any traction on it
and then tell us if you want money or
where you're at with the business sounds
good sounds good let's do it I'm Zayn
and I'm Matthew so we're building candid
at candid we apply generative AI to
blog-based social videos with the goal
of helping users get in touch with their
mental health all right but pause there
I didn't understand any of that so what
it's generative AI to help you get in
touch with my mental health through
Vlogs what would that what does that
mean give me what does that look like so
essentially we ask users to record daily
highs daily lows and then respond to a
thoughtful question which we Source from
psychologists and therapists then they
can choose which of any of these videos
they want to share with friends and from
these these videos we do topic detection
and sentiment analysis
um to present patterns to users to help
them get in touch with their mental
health so more specifically see you Vlog
and we give you insights into what's
going on in your life and help you make
sense
okay so like almost like an AI therapist
exactly it's like soft soft therapy yeah
I like to call soft therapy okay love it
none of that hard therapy Sam's been
doing for the last few years yeah
all right carry on yeah and before we
jump in we'd like to tell you a little
bit about the problem and and what we
were facing so both of us grew up
seriously struggling with mental health
I grew up in Thailand in Uzbekistan and
didn't have access to traditional
therapy and traditional resources and
Matthew grew up in San Diego and did
practically seek out those resources now
I found a couple of things and the thing
that worked best for me was generally
but the problem with drilling was that
it took three or four times to start
it's a hell of a hard habit to get to
stick so we started auditing around
Canada it was with the idea of making
drilling more accessible and more
engaging to users the problem's a lot
bigger than us though last year 40 of
students were in college experienced
depression and most of them didn't go
actively seeking out help our vision for
the future of consumer rental health is
that they're products that don't seem
and come off as Mental Health Products
but I was back in component that's
strong mental health focused
yeah so like I was mentioning at the
beginning what does that actually look
like a candid users record videos like
they would maybe on another type of
social media specifically highs lows and
reflective questions they can share
these videos with friends and then we
use a simple AI techniques to present
patterns to users so we do three things
for them right we transcribe the videos
we extract emotions we extract topics
and we do three things the first is we
identify patterns in people's lives so
let's say you're stressed about the
college internship surge right
um
and we we play that back for you and
help you observe and help you come to
your own conclusions about that the
second thing we do is we allow you to
Smart search through your memories so
you can search for emotions and topics
associated with the event you're trying
to look at right and then the last thing
we do is we build this Aura for you
every week which is a generative AI
visual
um for what you're
for what your week looked like
emotionally and it's a specific color
scheme built and tailored to you
yeah so is this an idea do you have
custody of users where are you guys at
right so right now we're in test flight
we have about 50 users we just closed
our precede we're in Dev and in
development mode right now we'll be
launching on the App Store in two to
three weeks and we'll be focusing
specifically on Stanford to really get
that product market and we have a lot of
customers say again
how are you going to get customers right
so we're going to launch at Stanford in
the next in the next month and that's
going to be a hard launch and we're
gonna use all sorts of distribution
strategies
and how much did you raise that you said
you raised the seed round or something
like that yeah of a half a million
dollars
wow from who a variety of these Seas uh
in in the Silicon Valley area uh reach
Yahoo OVO Z fellows uh StarTex
uh yeah okay I am GSR
and so you uh you're going to launch
that at Stanford cool and you can kind
of brute force that because you're there
you got friends you're on campus that
sort of thing what happens after that
how do you get this to like 10 000 users
or 100 000 users yeah absolutely so we
really do at first want to take a very
controlled approach so we're gonna go
campus to campus we're starting at
Stanford Lake Zane said we're gonna
really lock in the method that works the
best and then we're going to take a few
uh similar universities like Harvard
Caltech uh maybe some some universities
in in Los Angeles and take that same
approach and then grow from there so
we're looking at high stress
environments and we really don't want
like massive rapid growth we don't want
half a million users tomorrow because we
really want to test especially the
ethics behind us
um and ensure that this is something
that's scalable and like we're not doing
any active harm to users
all right all right so Sam let's let's
pause the pitch here and I want to get
your reaction to ideas let's say an idea
like this uh how do you think about this
either as an entrepreneur or an investor
what do you think as an investor I I
don't understand how it's the same thing
as before like when you just do the math
getting to venture size scale companies
which I don't know what that is 50 or
100 million in Revenue something like
that or a nine figure exit it's very
very very very very very hard when
you're only making a hundred dollars or
something like that a year per customer
that's just you just it's a very it's a
it's just a math problem uh it's very
challenging to do that particularly when
it's like a social ish app so as an
investor I don't think it's awesome as
someone working on it I think you guys
are in the best case scenario because
you have five hundred thousand dollars
and if this dies next next year then
it's like no big deal you're young you
did something amazing and you're gonna
have another swing so from your
perspective I think this is the greatest
thing ever from an Investor's
perspective
I'm not it doesn't it doesn't Tickle My
Fancy maybe because I don't see the math
on how it becomes huge do you agree we
have a friend who um has an app she
called rooted and it's basically around
panic attacks just similar space here
and what she found was she didn't raise
any money because she's not saying this
is going to be a billion dollar company
but it was a problem she had and she
wanted a solution for it and she knew
that other people have this problem
around panic attacks and it was too
Niche for like a a huge outcome but
because she built the company
in a way that suited how big that market
is she's going to be really really
successful with it right she's got seven
pieces of Revenue the only employees
herself she's the only employee it's
profitable and it serves that Nation she
acquires most of it
she has two million users by the way and
it could it could be a 10 million dollar
a year business with four or five people
right and so and she got she's getting
the growth through basically being the
top ranked search for if you search for
panic attacks like in the App Store so
she had a strategy around ASL right like
SEO like ASO App Store optimization uh
to be to be the top ranked term here and
so
um what I hear this idea I think these
guys you know first good for you for for
even doing entrepreneurship at this age
that's the first thing uh second good
for you for chasing uh like a problem
that that matters with you know cool new
tech so you're going to learn a bunch
about this problem you're going to learn
a bunch about this Tech
um good for you like Sam said for
raising some money so you know you're
going to have the ability to take a shot
at this if it doesn't work no harm done
you just got your first lessons under
your belt and you'll you'll do you'll go
on to have your second company third
company fourth company and one of those
will succeed
the thing I don't like about this is
that it's a lot of work and what you
know I think a lot of these Solutions
look really good in PowerPoint but when
they go when they go into the real world
people will simply not do the work to
help themselves it's like the guy who's
you know the very first pitch he's like
people get hearing aids and then they
get annoyed with them or the battery
dies and they don't plug it back in
right and then it sits on the Shelf like
adherence is a really big problem they'd
rather get dementia than charge their
their yeah put the battery out
um and and that's and so you know
customers go for for typically like the
low friction Solutions and so I think
what the challenge here is that you have
built something that doesn't really tap
into
human behavior the right way meaning
you're saying do the right thing it'll
help you and unfortunately people just
don't do the right thing and help
themselves and so I would love to see
you guys slim the product down into
something that is simple easier a little
more addictive to do and has some
variable reward that's like you know
worth the work that you put in if you've
ever read this book go go read hooked by
near IL uh have you guys ever heard of
that book yeah I've read it actually
it's a great book it's about habit
formation it's a great book and I would
basically say how can we make this a
more habit-forming product because right
now I would suspect that the work that
you're asking them to do which is
basically proactively go on video and
share what's on their mind is going to
be way too much friction for the average
person
um like you know so so I think you got
to find something that's simpler if you
want people to actually use it I think
Simplicity is at The Chronic support
we're trying to do I definitely think
you know we need to distill it even more
but really what we're trying to get at
here is tapping into people's existing
habit cycles of vlogging I think the
inflection point here is that our
generation is the first generation
that's like super comfortable just
getting in front of the songs and just
like you know spewing their [__] talking
their truth right
um and that's what we're really trying
to do you should make this detect you
should make it detect off of what
they're posting on social media then so
there's no extra work if if they're
already vlogging or if they're already
posting stories about stuff I wonder if
you could read that and give them some
insights and then that would hook them
to to pour out more maybe after that
because then you'd have a zero work
solution uh potentially like I don't
know the exact solution I just know that
I have made this mistake the reason I'm
saying this is I've made this mistake I
put in a PowerPoint deck what would be
an awesome product
and I didn't let reality into the room
and the real and when I let reality in
the room it was yeah users aren't going
to do all that work at the beginning so
then so they're never going to get the
benefits and um and so that's that's a
challenge I've had in the past and I
suspect this reminds me of mistakes I've
made in the past
are you guys dropping out what are you
gonna do once you have your 500k yeah so
we're actually taking the leave of
absence right now we're working
full-time on product smart
this is amazing man like look my my true
my my belief is that this is not gonna
work as you guys have it set up I think
that that's still a massive win for you
um and my like big takeaway is like
you we we say this a bunch how there's
like levels to this game of like
building stuff that makes money and
products that people like you guys are
like just this conversation you're very
clearly at the top of the top like you
know Luck's still gonna play a role and
you can still [__] all this up but just
the fact that you are where you are now
even though Sean said he's not a fan and
I said it the same thing
we're fans of you and you're gonna win
it's just a matter of is it going to be
this one or the next one or the next one
but this is really amazing this is a
classic thing of like I can't wait to
see your second company or your third
company
um because you know I had my sushi
restaurant as my first thing Sam had his
thing as his first thing
guys you guys are doing like you guys
are way way better you're just
generative generative hot dogs Sam would
generate them
I put them in the bun on my hand and I
handed them they were very generous you
had to be artificially intelligent to
eat them
the other thing I would say is um you
should stop calling it a leave of
absence and just start calling it a
leave of Excellence people like that
[__]
too
if anybody else ever wants to take a
leave of excellence and come work with
me for for a year come do that you can
email me shawnee.com
how old are you guys we're both 21. wow
well congratulations on your success and
uh thanks for doing this thank you guys
good to meet you awesome guys
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out-of-sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
next up what do we got simplify how many
more do we have by the way last one last
one last one we got Michael Mikey Mike
Michael the Meister so many different
names for this guy he's a great dude and
uh yeah you'll close this out strong
see that's what I miss about college I
used to have so many nicknames like what
they used to call me the blender because
uh somebody thought my last they thought
my last name was puree
so one guy was like yeah his last name
Fury right and they're like like the
blender setting so they call me blender
for like a year
it's pretty good I'll I'll start calling
you that uh Michael what do you got hey
Sam hey Sean I'm Michael I'm one of the
co-founders of simplify we're building a
career platform for Gen Z
what's the URL oh a simplified.jobs
because I know you aren't sitting on
that.com's got his b right now we're
gonna we're gonna get it here soon I
promise yeah I bet you will if you would
apply to a job today you'd quickly
realize how frustrating and broken the
process is that's super disorganized
jobs are scattered across dozens of
different job sites so when you're
applying you're you're going on 15
different sites it's super repetitive
today career counselors recommend that
candidates submit around 100 job
applications to just get one offer it's
also super noisy so existing platforms
like LinkedIn and indeed make it super
hard to actually find relevant positions
among the millions of different openings
out there
and you know as a student at Sandra
we've experienced this paid firsthand so
during my time in college I applied to
actually more than 200 jobs across 15
different job sites when I came to
school
um I grew up in small town in West
Virginia parents didn't work in Tech I
actually had no idea how to find my
first job
um and you know after trying all these
platforms we realized that the existing
Solutions out there really didn't work
so actually I actually met my first my
co-founders when we were applying a job
together so that it's actually kind of
nerdy even for standard Stanford
standards but um I think that's why we
decided to build simplify so when we
designed this platform we really wanted
to put the Canada experience first
um so you can kind of think of us like
by the way by the way I gotta stop you
I'm looking at your thing you're you
have a hundred thousand plus users that
have are using your Chrome extension in
three million applications and you
haven't said any of that yet well it's
not it's not section on the slide right
here so but yes
I gotta give you credit but I gotta say
also your bear you buried the lead dude
I don't pray that lead bro you're
killing it and uh for killing it pull up
pull up their site and put it in similar
web while he's talking yeah I'm there
we've definitely got some super exciting
traction so I think you can think of us
like the common application for jobs so
I think admit Yogi talked about applying
to college same process you come to our
website fill out this five minute
application that you can apply to
basically any job on the internet in one
click uh we've got a browser extension
that helps us do that so in the last
roughly year and a half when we launched
um we've gotten more than five million
applications submitted to our extension
which is saved like users over 70 000
hours of time uh We've also got a
centralized dashboard instead of like 20
different platforms so no matter what
site you're applying on uh we'll keep
track of your applications on simplify
in a kind of CRM type of thing so you
can stay organized throughout the
process
and finally with all this information
we've built this machine learning model
that is able to recommend you jobs based
on where you're applying and also based
on the profile that you filled out with
us so instead of scrolling endlessly on
sites like LinkedIn we'll actually
deliver you jobs in like a tinder-like
interface we can swipe yes or no and
apply to those jobs in one click
do you and you apply to them when you
swipe right uh so no you you we redirect
you to the career page in our browser
extension we'll auto fill the
information so it's effectively two
clicks
okay that's awesome but yeah so we so in
the last since launching in October of
2021 we've grown to over 150 000 users
and I think the most exciting part of
all of this is we actually spent zero
dollars in paid marketing
um so more than four million
applications submitted in 2022 we've hit
a million already in the first four
months of 2023. uh most front growth has
actually been organic I think we've
built a pretty exciting product that
really puts candidates first so we see a
lot of mentions on Reddit Discord GitHub
um we've also been able to build a
community around supporting people who
maybe first-time job Seekers
um so we write a newsletter that goes
out to 90 000 subscribers giving general
advice what on how to find your first
job
um I've also been able to find quite an
audience on LinkedIn by posting just
free career resources resume templates
list of opportunities I've garnered
around 60 000 followers in the last are
you a student or are you like 28 years
old and just snuck yeah I actually
turned 23 a couple weeks ago um so I
think I might be the oldest in the room
but
um
second oldest I'm a senior right now
but yeah and uh what's what's the uh how
do you make money right so we monetize
in a traditional like B2B sense where we
charge companies the ability to Source
through candidates and post jobs I think
what's super exciting about us is
through this common application we've
actually generated this super in-depth
profile on candidates so basically more
information that you get on a
traditional job application or on a site
like LinkedIn so that way as a company
if I want to say hey I want specifically
people at Stanford that were in their
society of you know women Engineers Club
that applied uh you know that studied CS
for two years and have two years of
python experience this is all
information that we have in a structured
format and we target your job listings
too
um and you know alongside that you can
Source through these candidates on our
platform so wait a second so companies
pay you to post the job you will show to
the audience where do they post that
where does that happen because you're
saying it's a Chrome extension and right
when you're just using Chrome you're
browsing the internet or you want to
apply to you go to a career page you can
click submit so where are they seeing
the job where's that that other side
yeah that's a fantastic question so it's
twofold so actually within our extension
when you click submit we'll actually pop
up relevant jobs so basically we're able
to kind of have a medium to four jobs
candidates no matter what site they're
on so even if you're on LinkedIn you
apply to a job
um this that post submission little
modal pops up and it'll recommend you
similar jobs um and companies have a
chance to advertise there well in
addition to that our matching algorithm
is kind of like the core part of the
business as well where through the
matches like candidates are specifying
exactly what companies that they're
looking for startups series a companies
you know companies that are founded by
women companies that are in specific
spaces so that gives us a very targeted
audience to show jobs too I think in the
last month or so I think we've had over
800 000 jobs showed
um just within the matches uh on so
check this out if you go to their site
you go to simplified.job scroll all the
way to the bottom they have this thing
that says check out some of our popular
job lists and they have things that say
top summer internships internships at
unicorns best remote internships
software roles at top YC companies they
have this really cool thing that says
Moon shots and you go to moonshots and
it says leading web 3 crypto and
blockchain startups the moonshot list of
2022 and so you can apply to some of
these moonshots uh
dude this is fascinating congratulations
like so far yeah so we're actually still
pre-revenue um right now really focused
on building out the consumer side of
things I think when we set out to this
we just really wanted to focus and make
sure that the consumer side was fleshed
out before we turned on the Jets on the
monetization side I will say the kind of
the way the product works now is we've
built these scrapers that pick up jobs
and like Sam mentioned
um of all these different opportunities
on the internet we put them into kind of
like playlists almost so you can browse
them almost like Spotify so if you know
you want to work with a unicorn here's
an example of jobs at these at these
specific companies and basically through
that we've actually been able to funnel
a lot of candidates into their existing
jobs so in the last couple of months
more than 50 companies have reached out
to us via emails we recently put up a
form that is now allowing us to collect
inbound from companies
um where they say they've actually hired
somebody that discovered that uh their
company on simplified uh so very soon I
think we're flushing out the recruiter
side of things allowing you to have a
self-serve model where you can post jobs
for months and and draw
you said 150 000 people use it how many
people have gotten a job from it right
so that's something that we're in the
process of figuring out so through our
CRM we can see how many people are like
in the interview process because people
generally use that to track where they
are just to keep organized for
themselves but once so how many
interviews I think we I don't have the
number on the top of my head but that's
something I can definitely pull up for
you um but what I want to say about just
give me an ish I think around like 30
um have reported like movement in their
job search process so whether that's an
interview whether that's they've gotten
rejected oh I think that's something
like 50 000 people have gotten a job
interview
Because of You ish I would say around
that yeah because I think we don't
really contribute to helping you get an
interview we just help you apply faster
I think that's the thing um a lot of
people ask like am I going to get a job
if I do simplify I think the goal is
just to make it easy to apply whether or
not you get an interview is still up to
you um that's kind of why we're
investing in the newsletter to help
people kind of actually learn the career
uh aspect so I kind of want to see
ourselves as like Credit Karma for jobs
so we can give you like hey you should
learn these skills if you're applying to
like 20 jobs you still haven't got an
interview I think that's kind of what
we're looking for explain how uh give me
the kind of like two line explanation
how does this get huge so how does this
become a massive company
um what would be your best pitch for
that yeah great question I think the
vision that we have is just to like be
in every single person's browsers then
uh be in every single person's browser
so we have a 90 retention rate on our
extension which is basically generally
the case for most browser extensions
people install them kind of forget about
them and they're only really pop up when
they're relevant so I think the goal is
to be able to make this Universal
everybody that's applying to jobs wants
the same time let's live in everybody's
browser extension
um so we have oversight on where people
are applying and through that I think
this gives us like a huge wedge in the
recruiting space the future of
recruiting I think is going to be all
data driven as an employer you want to
know like hey I want to Target people
that are applying to my competitors I
want to Target people that you know are
interested in software and current
platforms have very minimal visibility
on where people are actually applying
what jobs they're actually interested in
I think on LinkedIn I've been
recommended many jobs as like an
electrician or a plumber so I don't
really think that they know what I'm
interested in I think through kind of
art browser extension we're able to
collect the data and make the process
applying the job much more like
personalized and I think through that
companies are going to be signing up to
recruit on their platform and to post
jobs when they find out that their
Dollar on simplified goes a lot farther
um in making did you uh have you raised
money yeah so we actually just closed a
seed runs the first time we're
announcing it uh a couple weeks ago it
was a two million dollar round LED by
Craft oh wow okay well yeah I don't know
what the hell you're doing here but that
sounds awesome dude it says yourself so
listen to that where where is my email
yeah how did I not see this this is uh
now I'm upset you left me up Michael let
me read the uh let me read the team bio
so there's Michael here he's a designer
LinkedIn creator with 30 million views
and 60 000 followers uh rasheel is the
CTO he's an engineer and product
architect who scaled products to over a
million users and then there's Ethan the
CPO who you I guess he runs a career
newsletter with 90 000 subscribers are
those all accurate because that's a very
impressive uh Trio are they all students
too uh yeah we're well so actually we
interestingly we've all dropped out but
recently Ethan and I came back to live
on campus Because we both are on uh near
full scholarships at Stanford so we
basically get free housing here
um uh take a couple classes get free
housing it's a great it's a great gig uh
but we've been full-time on this for the
last year and a half
um and Rachelle lives in by the way in
San Francisco I like that you said
dropped out versus leave of absence
leave of absence is is uh you know one
foot in one foot out drop down is
committed right it's the uh the old pig
versus chicken uh breakfast breakfast
analogy the the chicken is involved but
the pig is committed you you're the pig
you guys are committed I like that
and uh uh you raised this two million
dollar round can you say the valuation
yeah so we raised out of 20 posts oh
[__] really
yeah good job they're YC they're YC it's
definitely tough Market but I think um
it's also an inflection point for us
where
um when the markets are rougher wait
wait wait you said tough marketers and
you think that's too low no in terms of
in general I think raising today is
pretty difficult I think we had a little
bit of a harder time but I think we
definitely benefited in the sense that
we've gotten a lot of growth uh really
tough to find a job these days so I
think uh job Seekers are more willing to
give like new startups a chance and I
think we've been able to capitalize that
when people install simplify they
generally don't uninstall and people
people seem to love the product so I
think we're super excited Michael this
is great I love the product I want to
invest uh I really like your approach
here I do think you know when I asked
the question of how can this be big and
you're you've had the kind of like the
what I'll call like the the vision
answer which is like what if everybody
what if everybody used this then it
would be big there's another way to kind
of think about that which is a Bottoms
Up way which says
you know we think on every customer
we're going to generate this much
revenue so with a hundred thousand
people or 200 000 people or a million
people using this extension we think we
would be generating 100 million dollars
a year right that would be you know so
so there's usually a formula that says X
users times y value per user equals z
you know revenue and so you know you
want to have that for you guys I know
you're quote unquote you know
pre-revenue so maybe you don't know
exactly how much your user is going to
be worth but it'd be good to have a
guess so that's kind of my only my only
like constructive feedback everything
else was was music to my ear so well
done definitely and I love these I love
these businesses uh I think the guy's
name is Ian Siegel I think that's the
guy started zip recruiter if I remember
correctly ZipRecruiter was like it had
the largest series a at the time like
five years ago ever it was like a 60
million series a because they
bootstrapped the business to many many
tens of millions in revenue and then
what's the guy's name Wilson what's his
first name is it uh
the guy who has uh Wilson or Union
ventures in New York I forget his Fred
Wilson he has this awesome blog post and
he's like uh we were seed investors of
indeed and it's the greatest business
model of all time because it's basically
Google AdWords uh you know like people
only it's like a paid performance type
of thing and it's one of the greatest
business I've had businesses I've ever
seen I love these types of businesses
because
they're perfectly aligned like the the
what you pay for you the pay for
performance is perfectly aligned all
everyone's incentives are pretty aligned
it would be even better if it was like
paid per job placement but that's a
little bit more challenging but so it's
pretty nicely aligned I think this is
awesome
yeah I know super really appreciate that
I think we're still working out the
business model right now we're trying a
subscription-based thing but definitely
open to to try new things so yeah would
love to hear feedback here's what Fred
Wilson said he goes
um
people you know one of the first grade
investment we made at USV was in the
summer of 2005 in in it for indeed and
they talked about the founders were
great the team was great blah blah he
says they have a product that's used by
80 million people worldwide every month
and they have a business model like
Google is the best on the internet
revenues profits customer satisfaction
shareholder value they've built a
fortress and I'm happy to have a seat in
the front row
um so that's uh that's that's pretty
cool uh well listen this is this has
been it's been awesome thank you for
coming up I think we have to announce
the winner so the winner is going to get
3 500 uh of the for the for today's
pitch competition I'm gonna message you
Sean who uh who what my winner is and
then you could yeah go ahead ask Bobby
what you want well I was gonna say how
did we settle on 3 500. it's a very uh
specific number here uh I mean bar shop
you might have a I have an opinion on
this that's like one souped up Mac you
know MacBook Pro or something
do you have Bobby like so you have a
Syndicate now like it would be very wise
if you just gave twenty thousand dollars
to every single person
and Sean you said something interesting
which is like why did I not hear about
this startup and there's what we've
learned is that angel investors are
having a damn hard time finding the top
college startups it takes a ton of time
to build these communities like we have
at Stanford and Michigan and so right
now we're trying to prove the model with
a Syndicate
um and helping support startups like you
saw today and like the ones you saw on
the Michigan show but the long run is
hope to do something just like you
mentioned there how old are you Bobby
are you in college still yeah I'm 22.
I'm a junior at University of Michigan
and so what happens in two years when
you're when you're out we're gonna we're
gonna change the world of college
entrepreneurship forever we started by
building communities for Founders and
now we're bringing in Angel Investors
into the mix we think that the way that
college entrepreneurship is fostered by
Institute centers clubs at schools is
bad and we think that the VC funds that
are targeting College entrepreneurs are
just looking for poached dealflow we
have a better way of doing it by
building the best communities and then
intelligently bringing in dope Angels
like you guys to make them make a lot
more interesting all right well
congratulations you're on to something
Sean and I have selected the winner and
um I don't Angel invest a ton not nearly
as much as Sean and out but so the
winner on this one I would love if you
guys would accept me I would put a very
small like five or ten thousand dollars
if you'd allow it but um I don't know
about you Sean I don't know if you're
you're in that same boat but we both we
both are aligned on who we think won
this one yeah I think you know what is
the best pitch uh who wins the pitch
competition it's the person who can have
a clear pitch that's compelling that
gets you excited and um and they're
committed I think that's the hardest
thing with investing in college
entrepreneurs is you don't know if next
semester
they're back re-enrolled in school it's
like Okay cool so now you're super
part-time on this like oh this is now an
extracurricular activity damn uh that's
not what I want like uh like those
fishing guys you know remember the the
guys who had the not the fishing the the
Boating company we loved it and they
were like yeah but you know we're in
college it's like well I don't want to
give you money then by the way I
invested in those guys and they are
going for it uh so they they are they're
pretty committed to it but I think it is
hard uh to know because you know it's
just one extra risk factor that you
don't have with somebody who's out of
school is like that they'll just get
sucked back in by Society to like the
safe path and so and by the way a lot of
times they should like go out there and
get laid and do whatever you want but if
you're gonna get after it I want you to
get after it like if I'm giving someone
money it's like I don't care this isn't
supposed to be cute like I want you to
give me more money back
[Laughter]
we have SIMPLE investment philosophies
yeah like when you say like well you
know but I learned a lot it's like yeah
I don't care I don't care what you learn
I care about me and my money so the
learning is great but it is second to
earning earning is always better than
learning it's the fallback right uh
anyways the business that we've both
selected is simply uh I think you could
probably tell from our excitement during
the pitch
you know it solves a real problem
simplify bro oh sorry simplify that jobs
um
yes yes there he is Michael from
simplify uh you are the winner of the
pitch competition you had the best pitch
you have the most traction you seem the
most committed that this is like
happening and there's no there's no way
out
um so congratulations you got you you
have done it yeah thank you guys so much
huge fan of the podcast and yeah
simplify I think it's a
we really got to get that URL for sure
you're never gonna get it you're never
gonna get it what are you gonna do with
this 3 500 Michael it's a great question
I think model service
hey if you guys want we can make that
happen but
um I think what's most important for us
is investing in our social channels I
think you know a huge fan of the podcast
um one of the hardest things for us is
getting in the hands of more college
students um our users have been super
helpful and kind of organically
spreading it we don't even have referral
rewards so they're doing it out of the
kindness of their hearts I think we want
to invest this and you know whether it's
our social media whether it's in on the
grounds kind of uh referral programs I
think these are all things that would
help us really take us to the next level
in terms of user growth you can either
get a little bit of LinkedIn promotion
or an eight-sleep mattress the the
answer is it's very obvious to me
frankly uh yeah this is 291 days of
Chipotle so that's a lot of fuel that
we're giving you first that is free for
you to go forward I get the mattress
think of us every day at lunch because
like this lunch was brought to you by my
first million every single day as you
build this company for 291 days and at
the end of that you're on your own Sean
let's do a wrap up here about like what
about these whole things I always I mean
we've only done it two or three times I
leave these things energized I also
leave these things intimidated
um so all every single person we've had
on this even if we've like given them a
hard time is incredibly impressive would
you say would you say so yeah I mean I
just remember where I was at that time
and it's you know we're not even in the
same room like I was I don't know where
I was but so so just putting yourself in
this position to be doing things like
this can make a pretty big impact I I
did this is actually how I became an
entrepreneur I did a pitch competition
my senior year second semester senior
year I had never even thought about
business before that I did a pitch
competition I ended up winning 25 Grand
and uh it changed the direction of my
life like I would I literally wouldn't
have been an entrepreneur had that not
happen and so and the idea was bad my
pitch was bad if I go back and look what
was it what was the 25-4
the Chipotle for sushi idea and those
those investors were horrible how did
they well there's we had two things
going for us one you know we had the the
most swag of anyone at the pitch
competition so we we gave the best you
know pitch I brought the Duke basketball
players in as a cameo during the pitch
they threw out t-shirts to the crowd so
we won extra money from the fans and
stuff like that but also one of the
judges he was worth like I don't know 20
50 million dollars something like that
and he did it because he owned 50
Applebee's so he was like oh restaurant
industry great industry to be in whereas
99 of the population would have said
that's a terrible idea but this guy had
made his living off of Applebee's uh and
so you know we had we had one judge in
the bag from that oh man that's a that
was the that competition was really bad
if they if you weren't because these are
so much better this guy just raised
money at a 20 million dollar valuation
from like you know a top 20 venture
capital I mean it's like pretty it's so
much better than when you and I were
doing this type of stuff yeah totally by
the way the funny thing is we run the
competition and then we also they also
paid for one MBA student to work for us
as an intern so they paid his salary and
we were like we were younger than this
guy this guy had worked like 70 years of
like real world experience before then
and so he was taking direction of these
21 year old idiots and we were like do
you know how to roll a sushi roll we
were just like yeah can you build us an
Excel model and he just and then he
would build it and we'd be like yeah you
know this doesn't look very good can you
just make it better and we just had this
guy work on an Excel model for like five
months he must have been like this is
the worst experience of my life well
congratulations guys you're you're
amazing Bobby good job organizing these
guys and uh I forget your the other guys
name who's the BMC over there but uh
good job uh uh yeah you what was your
name I know Anon good job uh you know
that energy that you have it's it's
really actually great for setting these
guys up you know because trading stuff
is really hard and like dude I don't
know if you guys have ever like done
High School sports but like when you're
lifting weights and like trying to bench
press a ton of weight and you have your
team around you who's like get it get it
like on that on that like when you guys
are trying to Max your bench or squad or
whatever that [__] actually helps and
you're kind of doing the same thing so
kudos to you it does actually help
psychon these guys up so congratulations
to everyone thank you guys so much and
Sean I'll just close like you mentioned
that gun on a uh the second semester or
senior year like pretty much changed
your future you guys are changing these
kids Futures like after the nursing
episode the amount of people that
reached out to us and like up close this
thing hit these people up hit me up be
housed with you mitch.edu hit these kids
up we're gonna put them up put the
descriptor like their websites their
emails in the description but like you
guys are changing these kids lives too
so we're damn we're damn great not
necessarily for the better but we're
changing them for sure
our lives are changing
we don't know which way it's going
though
I think that's the part
foreign
[Music]